I'm not going to be negative about our
experience at amusement park last
weekend I'm not going to say anything
about it you know in fact I loved it I
loved waiting in line for 2 and a half
hours for a ride that lasts 65 seconds I
I loved every second of it I love that
that's I was just waiting in that line
and I'm going this is great this is am
I'm so glad we're here doing this like
there are so many other things we could
be doing today and I'm glad we chose
this just wait just sitting here just
waiting in this line just standing here
that's the amusement park experience and
it's great that's what's so great about
it it's an opportunity to spend hundreds
of dollars waiting in line with fancy
impatient children and I'm not going to
be negative about it I'm not negative
I'm really not I think it's great